This lecture is about an overview of
statistical language models which cover
probabilistic topic models as special
cases.
In this lecture we're going to give an
overview of statistical language
models.
These models are general models that
cover probabilistic topic models as
special cases.
So first, what is the statistical
language model?
A statistical language model is
basically the probability distribution
over word sequences.
So, for example, we might have a
distribution that gives
"Today is Wednesday" a probability of 0.001
It might give
"Today Wednesday is" which is a non
grammatical sentence very, very small
probability as shown here.
And similarly another sentence, "The
eigenvalue is positive", might get a
probability of 0.00001
So as you can see, such a distribution
clearly is context dependent.
It depends on the context of
discussion.
Some word sequences might have higher
probabilities than others.
But the same sequence of words might
have a different probability in a
different context.
And so this suggests that such a
distribution can actually characterize
topic.
Such a model can also be regarded
as a probabilistic mechanism for
generating text.
And that just means we can view text
data as data observed from such a
model.
For this reason, we also call such a
model generative model.
So now
Given a model, we can then sample
sequences of words.
So for example, based on the
distribution that I have shown here on
this slide, we might, let's say, sample
a sequence like "today is Wednesday"
because it has a relatively high
probability, we might often get such a
sequence.
We might also get "the eigenvalue is
positive", sometimes with a smaller
probability.
Very, very occasionally,
we might get "today
Wednesday is" because the probability is
so small.
So in general, in order to characterize
such a distribution, we must specify
probability values for all these
different sequences of words.
Obviously it's impossible to specify
that, because it's impossible to
enumerate all the possible sequences of
words.
So in practice we will have to simplify
the model in some way.
So the simplest language model is
called a unigram language model.
In such a case, we simply assume that
text is generated by generating each
word independently.
Now, in general, the words may not be
generated independently, but after we
make this assumption, we can
significantly simplify the language
model.
Basically now the probability of a
sequence of words w_1 through
w_n would be just a product of
each.
The probability of each word.
So for such a model we have as many
parameters as the number of words in
our vocabulary.
So here we assume we have N words, so
we have N probabilities, one for each
word, and they sum to one.
So now we can assume our text is a
sample drawn according to this word
distribution.
That just means we're gonna draw
a word each time and then eventually
we'll get a text.
So for example now again.
We can try to sample words according to
a distribution.
We might get Wednesday often or today
often and some other words like
eigenvalue might have a small
probability, etc.
Now, with this we actually can also
compute the probability of every
sequence, even though our model only
specifies the probabilities of words.
This is because of the independence
assumption.
So specifically we can compute the
probability of "today is Wednesday".
Because it's just a product of the
probability of today, probability of is
and probably Wednesday.
For example, I showed some fake numbers
here and we might then multiply these
numbers together to get the probability
of "today is Wednesday".
So as you can see, with N
probabilities, one for each word, we
actually can characterize the
probability distribution over all kinds
of sequences of words, and so this is a
very simple model.
Ignore the word order, so it may not
be effective for some problems such as
speech recognition, where you may care
about the order of words.
But it turns out to be quite sufficient
for many tasks that involve
topic analysis, and that's also what
we're interested in here.
So when we have a model, we generally
have two problems that we can think
about.
One is given a model.
How likely we'll observe certain kind of
data points.
That is, we're interested in the
sampling process.
The other is the estimation process and
that is to figure out the parameters of
the model given some observed data, and
we're going to talk about that in a
moment.
Let's first talk about the sampling.
So here I show two examples of word
distributions or unigram language
models.
The first one has higher probabilities
for words,  text, mining, association,
etc.
Now this signals a topic about text
mining, because when we sample words
from such a distribution we tend to see
words that often occur in text mining
context.
So in this case, if we ask the question
about what is the probability of
generating a particular document, then
we likely will see text that looks like
a text mining paper of course.
...
The text that we generated by drawing
words from this distribution is
unlikely coherent, although the
probability of generating a text mining
paper publishing in the top conference
is non zero.
Assuming that no word has a zero
probability in the distribution and
that just means we can essentially
generate all kinds of text documents,
including very meaningful text
documents.
The second distribution show on the
bottom has different words that with
higher probability.
Food, nutrition and
healthy, diet etc.
So this clearly indicates a different
topic and in this case it's probably
about health.
So if we sample words from such
distribution, then the probability of
observing a text mining paper would be
very very small.
On the other hand, the probability of
observing a text that looks like a
food nutrition paper would be high,
relatively higher.
So that just means given a particular
distribution, different text will
have different probabilities.
Now let's look at the estimation
problem.
Now, in this case, we're going to
assume that we have observed data.
We know exactly what the text data
looks like.
In this case, let's assume we have a
text mining paper.
In fact, it's abstract of the paper, so
the total number of words is 100, and
I've shown some counts of individual
words here.
If we ask the question, what is the
most likely language model that has
been used to generate this text data,
assuming that the text is observed from
some language model, what's our best
guess of this language model?
OK, so the problem now is just the
estimated probabilities of these words
as I've shown here.
So what do you think?
What would be your guess?
Would you guess
text that has a very very small
probability or relatively large
probability?
What about the query?
Your guess probably will be dependent
on how many times we have observed this
word in the text data, right?
And if you think about it for a moment,
and if you like many others, you would
have guessed that text has a
probability of 10 out of 100.
Because I've observed text 10 times in
the text that has a total of 100 words.
And similarly, mining has five out of
100.
And query as a relatively small
probability, just observd once.
So it's one out of 100.
Right, so that, intuitively, is a
reasonable guess, but the question is
Is this
our best guess or best estimate of the
parameters?
Of course, in order to answer this
question we have to define what we mean
by best.
In this case, it turns out that our
guesses are indeed the best in some
sense, and this is called maximum
likelihood estimate.
And it's the best in that it would
give our observed data the maximum
probability.
Meaning that if you change the estimate
somehow even slightly, then the
probability of the observed text data
will be somewhat smaller.
And this is called a maximum likelihood
estimate.